اعلنها على فيسبوك انتحار شاب لاسباب
صادمه القصه
بعدت مصر وقعت انتحار لشاب قرر اعلان قرار
انهاء حياته عبر السوشيال ميديا سامح شاب
في مقتبل العمر من سكان اسكندريه عنده
انجازات كثير وكان واضح جدا انه محب
للحياه وله انشطه كثير منهم عملوا في
مدرسه رواد الفضاء
[موسيقى]
بدا من ايام ينشر بوستات على حساب وعبر
فيسبوك بتاعك الصرغبته في الموت فكتب قبل
انتحاره بيوم
[موسيقى]
يوفقك ثاني يوم اصدقاؤه ومتابعيه انه ذهب
للموت في وقت اسرع مما تخيلوا فنشر سامح
بوسط طويل بداوا بادعوا لي ربنا يسامحني
ما بقتش قادر استحمل اكثر من كده
[موسيقى]
مستر في البوست وروعه بعد التفاصيل من
معاناته الفتره اللي فاتت وانه كان
بيتعالج عند دكاتره نفسيين طبيب منهم قال
له عايز تموت نفسك روح وانه كان بياخذ سبع
برشامات في اليوم لمده ثلاث شهور كعلاج
[موسيقى]
وحاجه كمان ان في اثنين في حياته مش
هيسامحهم لانهم على حد وصفه دمروا حياته
وطلب سامح من متابعين واصدقائه انهم يحفظه
البوست ده ويحتفظوا سكرين شوت منه لانه
معتقد ان اخوه هيحاول يقفل حسابه ويلغي
البوست بعد ما يموت وده سبب لغز كبير جدا
عند الناس
[موسيقى]
سامح قبل ما ينتحر كتب كمان ان الحضن مش
رفاهيه ووصل ان ما حدش يحاسب غيره قبل ما
يحاسب نفسه
كمان اضاف سامح لينكات للكورسات اللي كان
بيقدمها للناس وطلب منهم ينشروها ويعيدوا
تقديمها للناس مره ثانيه كصدقه على روحه
وانهم يدعوا له ويفتكروا دائما
[موسيقى]
البوست انتشر بشكل سريع جدا و فورا بدات
الناس تنقسم بين متعاطف بشده وبين متسائل
ايه اللي زود ظاهره انتحار الشباب وليه
بيلجاوا لاعلان خطوتهم على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي
[موسيقى]